sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie sehr herzlich zum
pressegespräch mit
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
mit professor dr wolff kafka der
gemeinsam mit konrad lorenz max bleibt
institut geforscht hat und mit oberst
otto kopitzsch dem kommandanten des
militär hunde zentrums in
kaisersteinbruch und natürlich mit
unserem stargast fantasy forever von
seetang blickt ich glaube frau
bundesministerin versuchen zu beginnen
sehr geehrte damen und herren herr
professor herr oberst in zeiten der
korona krise beweist unser
österreichisches bundesheer unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten durch ihr
tägliches handeln welch unglaublich
unerlässlicher teil unserer gesellschaft
sie sind das beginnt gerade aktuell bei
der katastrophenhilfe
wenn wir an die schneemassen denken geht
über den grenzschutz in
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz oder im bereich der
botschafts bewachung sowie insbesondere
nach dem schrecklichen terroranschlag
notwendig oder auch bei den
flächendeckenden testungen sie wissen ja
wenn wir eine erste bilanz ziehen gerade
bei den testungen waren es über zwei
millionen die vorgenommen sind worden
sind über 4000 infizierte die wir auf
den aus dem kreislauf ziehen konnten
der österreichische bundesheer flexibel
vielfältig und professionell das sind
die unglaublich zahlreichen aufgaben die
tagtäglich geleistet werden aber heute
heute steht etwas ganz besonderes im
mittelpunkt und zwar aktuelle
forschungen aktuelle forschungen wie sie
derzeit das militär 100 zentrum zu grob
19 spürhunde ausbildung auch zeigt und
ich bin sehr dankbar herr professor dass
wir auf so unglaublich perfekte
wissenschaftliche expertise ja auch
zurückgreifen können das know how der
hundeführer auf das können unserer
vierbeinigen bediensteten damit wir in
zukunft dem dass carola virus schnell
und effizient doch detektieren können
ich bin wirklich sehr stolz darauf herr
professor und danke ihnen für ihre
arbeit herr oberst ihnen in den lehr 100
zentrum die expertise des
österreichischen bundesheeres ich denke
an der spitze gerade wenn wir am
vierbeinigen hunde auch denken nein
danke schön herr professor bitte vielen
dank dass sie uns nicht eingeführt haben
es ist eine tolle arbeit gewesen wir
arbeiten bereits 20 jahre sehr intensiv
sind mit lehrern und dozenten zusammen
über sprengstoffe in apothekers geld
geld prüfen und so weiter es war immer
sehr erfreulich und ich danke dir lieber
otto dass wir so gut kooperieren weil
die lange zeit
bitte bitte als nächstes jahr wusste ich
ja geehrte frau bundesminister sehr
verehrte damen und herren ich darf hier
kurz einige eckdaten zur ausbildung
dieses kowitz spürhundes der ja im
rahmen eines projektes das von der
zentralstelle über die frau
bundesminister im frühjahr dieses jahres
an uns herangetragen wurde
ich darf auch hier noch einmal betonen
dass wir was wir heute hier sehen was
sie sehen werden was wir hier auch
darstellen
auch vom wissenschaftlichen standpunkt
her ist ein zwischenbericht
das heißt die ausbildung ist noch lange
nicht abgeschlossen die erfahrungen sind
noch lange nicht alle gemacht aber ist
ein zwischenbericht der uns eigentlich
guter hoffnung macht wir haben im früher
begonnen uns zu überlegen
nachdem der auftrag gekommen ist wie
kann man
spürhunde zur detektion von kubik 19
ausbilden
ihr habt dann eigentlich relativ schnell
mit unserem gegenüber aus deutschland
herrn professor kafka kontakt
aufgenommen mit dem wir bereits über 20
jahre nach seiner methode spürhunde auf
sprengstoff suchtgift und auch
kampfmittel mittlerweile entsprechend
und auch erfolgreich ausbilden
wir haben dann durch eine kooperation
mit dem streitkräftebasis
sanitätszentrum süd und einer klinik in
graz
hier kommt aktives material erhalten und
dies aus diesem kowitz aktiven material
hat professor kafka entsprechende
ausbildungs hilfsmittel hergestellt wird
dann selber noch im detail darüber
berichten und mit diesen ausbildungs
mitteln die dann im juni dieses jahres
zu gelaufen sind haben wir mit der
hundeausbildung entsprechend begonnen
es war dann natürlich auch jetzt so
genannte aha effekt eingetreten da kann
ja so oder so sein
wir haben ja überhaupt keine oder die
wissenschafter und mikrowellen einsam
was die geruchs feststellung betrifft
überhaupt keine erfahrungen und also
dann im heeresspital die erste aktive
cupid 19 probe aus dem gartenzimmer den
hund paar minuten später vorgelegt haben
hat der hund diese prognose eine probe
vorher noch nie abgeführt hat sondern
nur die ausbildungs hilfsmitteln aus dem
labor eindeutig und auch sofort
angezeigt also ich kann die frage die
auch hier diesem erprobungs auftrag den
wir von der frau bundesminister haben so
beantworten ja die hundenase ist in der
lage mit infiziert das material zu
detektieren und anzuzeigen
das muss man jetzt in nächster zeit noch
durchführen und auch die erfahrungen die
wir hier gewinnen müssen ist der hund
braucht entsprechende routine da wir
doch selbst ist er in einer gewissen
weise sehr komplex ist und auch auf die
viruslast
es kann durchaus sein das attest was aus
sagt unterhalt noch nicht einen tag
später der hund die gleiche probe sehr
wohl anzeigt weil die wir durchlaufen
eine andere ist und weil die proben
älter sind oder die krankheit abflacht
das durchaus auch sein kann dass der
hund es nicht mehr anzeigt oder der hund
anzeigt unter das nicht das heißt diese
aktionen schwarz weiß oder rot grün wie
bei einer ampel kann man bei dieser
komplexen aufgabe wirklich momentan
nicht anwenden und für uns ist jetzt
wichtig in den nächsten monaten müssen
denn york bis über den jahreswechsel
hier die erfahrungen so weit fertig zu
machen dass diese erprobung spricht dann
in einen in eine endfassung gelangen
kann wo wir dann beurteilen ist das
einsetzbar ist es nicht einsetzbar wenn
man sich vorstellt es ist ja nicht auf
jedem grenzübergang ein sprengstoffhund
gemeint sondern das schwergewichts
aufgaben
es kann sein dass kurve dem früher
besiegt ist was mich alle hoffen
aber ich glaube an der
wissenschaftlichen und der akademische
nutzen dieser erprobung ist ein sehr
großer weiß kann die nächste krise
kommen und wenn der nächste krise kommt
haben wir zumindest soweit vorbereitet
dass wir das handwerkzeug haben hier
etwas dagegenzusetzen mit hunden im
konkreten zum wissenschaftlichen teil
bevor ich dann die vorführung selbst
moderieren darf weder professor kampker
suchen einige worte zu sagen vielen dank
herr minister ja es gibt inzwischen
viele wie ton immer ein komet nachweisen
krank und möchte man jetzt eher zäh
bedeutete dann die klinischen tests
antikörper bindung und schließlich die
diagnose über krankheitssymptome
alle diese drei methoden haben nachteile
erstens einmal sind sie sehr langsam
zweitens sagt ein sehr guter test der pc
hat es zwar aus du bist cupid infiziert
aber wissen noch nicht deswegen ob er
auch eine krankheit ausgelöst hat der
klinische test sagt nur aus also der
soli modell antikörper antigen test sagt
nur aus dass ein qubit vorgang
stattgefunden hat er sagt nicht aus aber
noch statt weiter stattfindet oder ob
die chinesen schon eingetreten ist
darüber können wir noch nichts sagen und
die gesundheits aussagen sind natürlich
auch abhängig von dem mediziner der
diese prüfung macht also wenn einer kein
geschmack mehr hat das eine typische
folge von kuwait belastungen ist dann
ist das ein hinweis aber auch kein
hundertprozentiger hinweis geruch kann
auch manchmal so alleine aufhören
deswegen wurden schon vor kurzer zeit
auch hunde eingesetzt aufgrund des hohen
berufs aber auch diese haben ihr
nachteil denn die proben an denen die
hunde ausgebildet wurden stammten aus
unterschiedlichen zeitabständen nach
infektion einmal achselschweiß einmal
urin einmal speichel oder stuhl den fall
sehr komplexe vorgänge oder blutabnahme
solche wurden in england frankreich
deutschland auch in finnland gemacht
also der nachteil daran liegt dass die
proben einmal nicht sauber klar gestellt
sind aus welcher phase der entwicklung
im körper diese stammen und zweitens
wurden die ge sicherheits experimente
sicherheitsvorkehrungen die
gefahrstoffverordnung bilder verordnung
nicht sauber erfüllt also ein risiko für
den hund und auch verschuldung von durch
diesen hund neues jetzt das leben
aufgrund dieser einladung versucht haben
ein sachs material herzustellen
das dem zur ausbildung genutzt wird das
wären heißt es eine schnelle training
und schnelle prüfung erlaubt es war
schon im hintergedanken ein
routineverfahren zu entwickeln das die
kopitzsch grad vorgestellt hat dann für
den späteren einsatz im notfall auch
wieder weiter verfolgt werden kann
was ist sex das ist ein kleines röhrchen
auf dieses wirklich nehmen sie jetzt in
die hand es ist ja sonst darf man das
nicht in die hand nehmen
nicht weil es gefährlich ist sondern
weil es kontaminiert wird doch nicht das
ist ein kleines röhrchen auf dieses
werden die duftstoffe ausgetragen die
dann für den wirkstoff den man erkennen
will verantwortlich sind zum beispiel
sprengstoff oder drogen material oder in
diesem fall das erst diskutieren
material das zur erkennung von covidien
der vorteil von diesem material ist dass
man auch mehrere komponenten
gleichzeitig aufladen kann zum beispiel
verschiedene narkotika heroin kokain
morsey in op usw
das hat dann den vorteil dass der hund
nicht an jedem stoff extra ausgebildet
werden muss sondern auf einmal auf alle
stoffe ausgebildet werden das erspart
zeit für die gesamte ausbildung auch das
ist kostengünstig und der zweite
wesentliche vorteil ist wenn sie
sprengstoff in einer so niedrigen
konzentration wie hier auf so einem
röhrchen haben dann ist keine
gefahrstoffverordnung mehr gültig das
heißt sie haben keine lange prozesse
wenn sie irgend einen transport machen
weiß sprengstoff müssen sie jemand
transport anmelden und dann müssen
sicherheitsvorkehren müssen bestimmte
lager haltungen einhalten ist es sehr
aufwändig und ihnen einmal vorzustellen
wie viel da drauf ist das ist ungefähr
nun kommen und dann kommen neun oder
zehn oder elf oder zwölf 0
und dann kann also das kann man sich
nicht vorstellen
beispiel sind eben ein bisschen zucker
also einen würfel und schmeißt dem
neusiedler see zum beispiel ungefähr
ganz grob und dann hören sie hier
und dann finden können sie noch
nachweisen dass der zucker darin gelöst
ist das ist die verdünnung und davon
geht jetzt noch mal ein kleiner anteil
ableiten zehntausendste und das kann der
hund noch wahrnehmen also das sind schon
extreme bedingungen und man muss sich
auch die frage stellen warum kam der
hund das machen
er kann ja kein sprengstoff bedeutet
keine biologischen sinn sehen
sprengstoff körperlich zu seiner futter
qual und auch sonst irgendwas versuchen
was ist eigentlich los und jetzt gibt es
inzwischen verschiedene sox qualitäten
es gibt für sprengstoff für geld
papiergeld für leichenzug und in
apothekers für wildtiere also
artenschutz tiere für bettwanzen was im
riesen renner ist derzeit und praktisch
für alle stoffe die eine geruchlich
wahrnehmbare substanz abgeben
dafür kann man songs erstellen fox ist
kurzform von den assistenten die mir bei
der entwicklung oder bei der forschung
geholfen haben dieses herzustellen das
ist vor etwa 20 jahren passiert oder
mehr als 20 jahren so und was ist jetzt
auf dem socs für den move it drauf wir
wissen es nicht was ja moleküle sind
aber wir haben wie schon gesagt hatte
material von der klinik in uni klinik in
wien über die mithilfe des
militärhospitals in graz entschuldigung
beides aus graz bekommen und haben von
diesem material das aus verschiedenen
belastungs zuständen entstanden also
frisch womit belastet bis zu dem punkt
wo der mann schon mit sauerstoff
intubiert wurde und sie wissen alle dass
sauerstoff innovationen meistens als 50
prozent der sauerstoff integrierten
haben die scoop it nicht überlegt wenn
man so etwas praktisches gesamte band
der möglichen körperlichen sekundär
produkte die durch das virus entstehen
sei es in der lunge sei es im herzen der
nieren oder im
das könnt und im herz das könnte also
alles drin sein so damit haben wir also
ein sachs co erstellte sind da einen
flaschen verborgen ich habe ihn so ein
röhrchen gezeigt als beispiel und mit
denen wurde der hund ausgebildet so das
war die spannende frage des ausbildung
des lichtes komplizierte die spannende
frage wo das herz wirklich stehen bleibt
ist taucht das ganze etwas denn ich muss
einen hunde ausbilden der sehr viel geld
kostet die ausbildung kostet geld die
zeit investiert ist und auch das
vertrauen das die leute geschenkt wird
dich sagen wir machen das für euch
kopierens war das steht alles dahinter
und dann kommt eine mitteilung der hund
hat diese maske angezeigt das ist also
der hammer an der sache und deshalb
natürlich sehr erfreut
ich glaube dass wir mit dieser
entwicklung oder dass österreich mit
dieser entwicklung eine spitzenposition
international einnimmt
denn wir haben ein sehr sicheres
material des absolut virenfrei oder auch
die testung erfolgt sodass eine viren
übertragung praktisch nicht möglich ist
denn das material das wir erhalten
prüfung benutzt das also ist der stand
jetzt gibt es natürlich und nachfragen
was bedeutet es wenn der hund eine maske
anzeigt von einer person die nicht
korrekt pc eher positiv getestet wurde
das könnte daran liegen dass kurve der
rcp ist es praktisch 100 prozent sicher
und sauer
der fehler könnte sein in der
probennahme und wenn sie mit den nasen
stäbchen darum gehen das treffen sie oft
nicht die stelle wo dieser kommt sich
niedergelassen
hat das ist immer ein problem dieses zu
finden können denn eine fall sein
jetzt könnte aber auch sein dass der
hund eine positive probe nicht anzeigt
was ist da passiert das kann sein
kopitzsch und erzählt hatte dass der
infektions vorgang noch nicht so weit
gelaufen ist das schon produkte im
körper entstanden sind die der hund dann
wahrnehmen kann
in diesem fall muss diese tests noch
einmal nachgedacht werden
eine weitere frage ist die sich dann
anschließend wird wie schnell ist das
der kommunikations vergangen erkennbar
wie lange ist ja erkennbar vom
bundesminister ich habe sie gefragt
haben sie eine alte maske die würde ich
gerne testen weil es könnte sein dass
wollen gesund gott sei dank
könnte sein dass unter wasser doch
angezeigt wird das sind wichtige fragen
die zu klären sind
ansonsten thema offen für fragen
ich möchte also ganz ausdrücklich noch
einmal danken für diese möglichkeit
hierzu kooperieren es waren spannende
hoch spannende sache und wir kommen
jetzt so praktischen vorführung wir
wollen ihnen jetzt den und den wir so
weit ausgebildet haben das in der lage
ist kurvig infiziertes material
anzuzeigen
kurz zur erläuterung sie senta trömel
das glas mit der mit dem mund nasen
schutz der herausschaut
die probanden denen wird entweder im
krankenzimmer oder bei einer probe ein
mund nasenschutz abgenommen der circa
fünf minuten beatmet wird die leute
stecken diesen schutz sofort in diesem
glasbehälter hinein und die glasbehälter
werden dann dem hundeführer übergeben ja
die hier in diesen trägern entsprechend
platziert der hund wird jetzt ein glas
nach dem anderen ab spüren eine der
proben ist positiv mit einer positiven
probe versehen und der hund sollte die
positive probe zur hinlegen oder
hinsetzen anzeigen daher
oberwachtmeister faymann ist der
ausbildungsleiter der hier mit seiner
fantasy von 1
an dieses projekt entsprechend auch
betreut und umgesetzt hat wie gesagt das
ist der halbe weg wir haben dann weg vor
uns haben
es schaut aus als wäre es sehr
vielversprechend herr orchester bitte
sehr
sie sehen das glas mit der infizierten
maske hat der hund eindeutig angezeigt
wir tauschen das jetzt noch mal machen
im zweiten durchgang das ist natürlich
keine spielerei war für den hund es
durch seine erste aufgabe ja hier
konzentriert zu suchen und vor allem der
geruch von sonnen von abraummaterial
interessiert mich nicht wirklich nicht
dass es rein konditioniert worden darauf
wenn er den geruch anzeigt wird da mit
dem krieg oder mit futter belohnt
also ich glaube es ist relativ
überzeugend dass die aussage die wir
vorher gemacht haben
auf halben weg dieses erprobungs bericht
das so genau dass die hundenase
eindeutig in der lage ist co witt
aktives material anzuzeigen
wir haben bei dem hund immer die gleiche
methode angewandt das haus die die leute
oder die probanden haben und nasenschutz
masken fünf minuten in etwa beatmet die
wurden einen glas verschlossen und dann
dem hund zur suche angeboten was
vielleicht interessant ist wir haben
auch versucht immer die gleichen
umfeldbedingungen zu haben wie man es
vor so gehört haben von der wissenschaft
der virus ist sehr komplex auch die
ausbildung ist komplex somit braucht der
hund hier klare rechtliche immer das
gleiche geschaut von hund immer gleich
aus damals am proben trendy positiv
seien dann sucht er wieder viertelstunde
lang nichts anzuzeigen ist weil nur sich
hinzulegen weil ich eine belohnung
wählen obwohl die pro minute ist es soll
ja kann sehen das heißt der hund braucht
hier entsprechende routine von der nase
her kann er es eindeutig leisten danke
ja herzlichen dank ich versuche jetzt um
ihre fragen wenn es fragen gibt die
kurze hand heben dann mit dem mikrofon
hinkommen können
entschuldigen sie bitte bis das mikrofon
da ist werde man sich nämlich nicht
vielleicht könnten sie das sind auch
einmal ganz knapp und kurz erklärt was
genau kann der wind da jetzt riechen
wenn man von kogit positiven material
sprich was ist das genau das können wir
nicht genau sagen wir sind ziemlich
sicher dass es nicht der kogit der virus
das virus selber ist es könnten virus
anteile dabei sein weil wenn der in die
zellen ein wandert dann werden viele
stellen frei gesetzt von ihm und dann
zerfällt er teilweise es könnte sein
dass es diese komponenten sind es könnte
aber auch sein dass die eiweiße die von
der zelle ausgebildet werden die dann
wieder in den indigo klose eingebaut
werden was die auch einige hoch erzeugen
und den ganzen zytokinen die da im
laufen sind im prozess wir wissen nicht
genau die mengen sind auch zu gering als
dass bedürfen masse was einen
spektrographen gc methode dar was ein
bisschen vielleicht später mal ja danke
gut gibt's weitere fragen
wie lange ist so ein hund ein stück für
so eine eine übung einsetzbar und und
was sind praktische anwendungsgebiete
sich vorstellen können sobald die
ausbildung abgeschlossen
ich muss wieder zu meiner antwort zurück
kommen die vorher gesagt ob dass dies
ein zwischenbericht ist und wo wir die
hunde einsetzen können ob wir sie
einsetzen können wird dann am ende
dieses berichtes herauskommen ist klar
es wird anfang des nächsten jahres sein
dass es keine flächendeckende geschichte
ist wieder brauchen wir für ganz
österreich wahrscheinlich tausende hunde
und dass privatpersonen nicht mit cupid
infektiösem material herum
experimentieren kann schwer vorstellen
aber ich würde mal sehen von von dieser
variante her dass das vielleicht auf
jeden fall in schwergewichts bereichen
einsetzbar ist wie sogar vielleicht im
bereich von von von wichtigen
konferenzen dass man hier nichts
einschleppt im bereich von zentralen
drehscheiben wie zb ein internationaler
flughafen schwechat ob man vielleicht
für die zukunft flieger aus
krisengebieten oder aus risikogebieten
routinemäßig kontrolliert zu wenig sagt
ob das sagen hat auf jeden
grenzübergangs technik ein
sprengstoffhund dort aber man kann bis
zum gewissen grade schwer gewichtsmäßig
solche einsätze andenken das wird sich
dann herausstellen
wir sanieren kaisersteinbruch keine
keine riesige ausbildungs anlage mit
zigtausend von hunden wir haben 60
kunden ständig in kaisersteinbruch und
20 hundetrainer
wir bringen schon etwas zuwege aber
diese sicher eine sache die
schwergewichts mäßig auch einschätzbar
ist ungefähr man das dann aus rollen
kann auf andere exekutiv bereiche das
wird man dann sehen wenn die erprobung
fertig ist von der sache her als er
gesehen wie schnell dieser und diese
proben absucht es ist ja keine große
herausforderung für den hund für die
suche weil der ablauf und das szenario
immer das gleiche ist also wieder mal
probiert also 200 proben in zehn minuten
250 proben ist überhaupt kein problem
und von der sucht zeit würden wir
ungefähr so ähnlich wie bei der suche
wird euch mein stock suche 30 minuten
wenn der hund nach einer suche von 30
minuten kommt darauf an auf die
umfeldbedingungen ist es sehr heiß ist
es klimatisiert wenn es ja haasis die
hundheimer angolaners verrückt aber doch
seien die suchzeiten natürlich kürzer
gut dann gibt's weitere fragen
vielleicht allgemein eignet sich da
jeder hund für eure ausbildung
ich sage im grunde ist jeder hund der
gewisse voraussetzungen hat für eine
solche ausbildung geeignet er braucht
natürlich gewisse voraussetzungen wie zb
einen sehr hohen spielt trifft er
braucht eine entsprechende nasen
leistung und er braucht da ein
entsprechenden charakter die hunde
werden ja bei uns beim militär nur
deshalb nach rasen ausgesucht weil wir
bei den rasen auch die
charaktereigenschaften mit einfließen
lassen wir wissen belgische schäferhund
ist hervorragend der suche und mit einer
guten nase ist sehr temperamentvoll und
ist auch sehr spielfreudig wenn er jetzt
vielleicht der droge hernehmen gehabt
vielleicht eine gute nase aber ist für
diese art der arbeit sicher nicht
geeignet weil sie schneller mail wird
weil sie nicht so beweglich ist also
grundsätzlich kann auch ein mischling
sorgen dafür geeignet sein aber wir
testen auch eine hunde bevor sie in
diese ausbildung gehen mit normierten
des ob sie den trip an ob sie die die
die spielfreude haben und ob sie
entsprechende durchhaltefähigkeit um
weil es nutzen so konnte er nur zwei
minuten spielen und dann hat nur jetzt
auf deutsch gesagt es ist wahnsinn warum
wir hier schäferhunde im allgemeinen
einsetzen wobei so wir haben einen
zweiten hund vom herrn wachtmeister
rechts und rothweiler auch in diesem
erprobungs programm drinnen weil dann
runter vom charakter wieder komplett
anders ist wird der belgische schäfer
und viel ruhiger der sucht auch viel
ruhiger könnte sein dass du später
vielleicht der vorteil ist
haben fürs kampfmittel spüren beim
militär unterzentrum zum beispiel vor
sechs jahren eine neue hundehaus sie
eingeführt der labrador retriever wieder
ein hund der sich aufgrund seiner
gewissen charakter an der rasse
typischen eigenschaften besser eignet
als eine andere hunderassen das
hundehaus und beim militär haben
hauptsächlich den zweck weil man den
charakter und das verhalten des hundes
bereits im welpenalter voraussagen kann
wenn man ein leben mischling aus dem
tierheim wo ich bin ich vielleicht fürs
ganze leben mit dem hund auch sehr
zufrieden kann einmal von journalisten
und auch vorstellen aber ich kann im
vorhinein keine aussage treffen was der
hund für leistungs qualitäten und
vertrieb anlagen hat vielleicht ja ganz
kurz bevor der professor zum wort kommt
die da sind ist inzwischen berichtet als
ich glaube die sensation oder ist er
professor gesagt hat war zu dem
zeitpunkt da wo warum dem angeschlagen
hat die frage wo die einsatzfelder sind
das ist jetzt noch alles in der prüfung
das werden wir sehr gern dann anfang des
nächsten jahres kundtun
ich glaube gerade was die rassen die
dafür einsatzfähig sind
da ist schon von der wissenschaft glaube
ich noch einiges an arbeit auch
notwendig und ich freue mich dann wenn
wir uns dann beginn des nächsten jahres
dazu sehen ich glaube stolz kann uns
alle machen dass wir wirklich in
österreich mit dieser forschungen an der
spitze sind und herr professor sie
werden sich als noch was zu der frage
der rassen die dazu geeignet sind seien
sicher werde ich jetzt mir gedanken
machen zu den rassen
aber ich möchte dass wir sie haben den
richtigen land eine offizielle anfrage
von der universität padua bekommen haben
können wir mit uns kooperieren
und das wird in dem man zugeleitet und
das freut mich sehr und diese
universitäts parteiarbeit speziell der
frage nach was ist im verhalten von
hunden interessant dass es wichtig und
vielleicht können die uns in dieser
frage welcher hund funktioniert
weiterhelfen ich selber habe mal ein
mops gehabt also kurz im mund oder nase
er hat genauso gesucht wird
andere aber ich weiß nicht ob der
technisch einsetzbar ist ja aber es
interessant entschuldigung wir
verbrochen hat jetzt die frage in den
raum was kopitzsch immer noch einen
durchgang machen können gibt es
technisch oder probieren schwärme
gesehen das funktioniert sie kennen den
vorführeffekt aber ich glaube die
fantasy wird auch den dritten durchgang
noch schaffen
soweit mir bekannt ist gibt es glaube
ich auch videomaterial das ihnen zur
verfügung gestellt werden kann
frau roth stimmt es wenn notwendig aber
ich glaube wir werden daraus sicher
etwas zusammenbringen mit dem sie etwas
anfangen können
ich habe bilder sagen mehr als tausend
worte kamen schon gut wenn es keine
weiteren fragen gibt und sage ich
herzlichen dank und behinderte
pressekonferenz dankeschön dankeschön
[Musik]